this is sibling rivalry on we're back
and we're very cold yes it was a it's
like what is that sign native i-20
something like that yeah
but we we just got back from the movie
like yeah like right now uh so uh we're
gonna tell you our thoughts on it um
just short version it's pretty cool yeah
for the MA
[Music]
that was good yeah nope I don't think
anybody's gonna sit here and say this
was the greatest Star Wars movie ever
it did have it is awesome yeah it is the
darkest this shit Star Wars movie at
least since this and probably Empire
Strikes Back and wow it's just some
fucking I feel like going into it I mean
kind of losing yeah we won't go into
spoilers but you look at the trailer is
it's pretty much the film you think you
we're going to feel the Death Star plans
what do you think is going to happen
yeah yeah it is it's not horrible right
what you probably think is going to
happen will happen
this is very much where I think uh and
that's pretty much the plot I mean it's
like there's a whole bunch of FAA
through it it make it way more conflict
I didn't get that a lot more complicated
but now that's really is and this is
definitely a movie where it's the in
some ways is different than force
awakens tabi opposite yeah is because
force awakens I thought the first half
was actually pretty strong and then the
the space battle at the end I thought
was kind of like this one the second
half is a really long is really frickin
good like some of the best Star Wars
material I've seen well particularly
going back to Empire yeah like and the
action is some of the best action but
yeah it's a slow start like because the
movie starts off really kind of slow
edge in the movie honestly um and I
would say that the big focus is not as
much on the characters it is it is more
still
based even though it is kind of a simple
story but I try to make it more
complicated to go to this place now this
place now this place and you know it is
it's like a mission impossible or James
Bond Ville it's like an exotic locale
every like the first three minutes of
this movie they're just throwing out
planet names and it's always just looks
like a bad program what I swear it's an
anagram for Obi one day one else see
that I'm gonna you want my body or so
long and I just like zombie wanted only
wanted but yeah and it just pops from
planet to planet and they do explain the
pop of it it's I'm not sure that it's
been I was confused and wasn't following
it or I just wasn't been invested
because I'm kind of like well I know
what's going to happen there will be
Death Star plans they need to get stolen
that is the one problem with you when
you throw these films together and
they're between two other movies well
that my god a sorry I don't need to know
the details because I know what's going
to happen I think that is the one major
weakness of the film is that even though
there are good characters in this I do
like to go check the characters the main
two are really dull uh and they're not
like awful actors right doing there you
know looking over like oh don't say suck
or anything like that
oh and I'm also very both of them had
some great yeah acting scenes it's is
nothing interesting yeah I know and what
kills me is I'm like they should have
been easy to make interesting so I can't
I can't figure out where the failure one
I know I got high side characters were
really are a lot of fun um amazing I
feel like you could have gotten and
these actors did fine don't get me wrong
it wears by no means bad but I know you
could have gotten some more interesting
character actors in there like for the
main lead I imagine like a Michelle
Rodriguez or something like that and
they're just a really cool badass like
you're just always looking busy I mean
that very minute I'm gonna that'd be so
awesome I feel like their story too
because I not knowing a ton going into
it because I was trying to avoid some of
the trailers I thought the story was
going to go one direction with her path
or whatever and instead of one another
and the one they went with I felt was
okay there's your standard story like I
don't know I didn't say I don't think
it's a spoil all right so I that you can
say we saw because I think it's actually
I think it would have made it more so
but it's too kid what was her father's
and Galen I think so yeah so there's
this two characters and I did it's very
late and I'm tired so no I don't
remember all the characters from this
movie when I got these names with many
which remember which may be a bit of a
problem like that maybe in the kidded
that I didn't care as much in some
respects about this I don't know but so
her father works as a scientist and
Imperial engineer and helps design the
dust are against his own wishes or will
or whatever the Empire is basically
forcing him to do it and then there's an
Imperial officers basically holding his
you know feet for the flames to get him
to do this and I thought kind of like
when I first saw images and everything
that her father was going to be that
imperial officer that will not enough
assign a lot more insurance and I'm like
that would have made it way more
interesting and and instead it's just
your standard just like oh my dad didn't
want to do this is an eye of the fight
for my dad because you know I build a
Death Star and I gotta steal the plans
of the Standen it's fine it's just I
don't know I thought like there were
ways that you could have actually made
this story yeah I felt like that you
know the interesting stuff in the movie
that really made it stand out
character-wise you know there is a I
called c-3po if you suck the pussy out
ah ha ha ha he would like to yeah badass
yeah yo maybe I she's like really really
I'm amazing um that Jedi like is I guess
in this out what is it is like video'll
Jedi temples I guess they had like
guards and so some of these guards still
just remain only they're out of a job
because of a Jedi are dead and the one
these is like a blind guard who just is
like almost a zealot but he's always
like the forces with me I'm one with the
force it keeps saying this prayer and he
has this partner who is much larger guy
who always protects it yeah and there
Palmer house is true were me one is
totally unfazed
I even though we fly in the other it's
like I you just got you and make your
own luck and stuff and they both really
truly depend on each other and it really
felt like somehow the Curacao feel
there's a traitor there's a defector
Imperial pilot yeah he was a kind of
kickstart owning the villas on the
villain the villains a lot of fun like I
just I was telling Doug in the middle of
the film movie I just was like I could
watch this guy just be pissed all day
like you just every single thing goes
wrong for this poor schmuck he's always
with oh I feel like this guy's whole
performance can be something even though
he never says it just him going hello
yeah I forgot he'll perform I know that
was my favorite scenes like explosions
at the Imperial base and he's staring at
this happening from some tower high up
and the rest of the officers is staring
with him but he just turns around he's
like what are you waiting for it's
tender gary said love your father yeah
are you wrong um the stuff that really
uh the stuff that really stands out to
me that I always I like you when they do
this in movies I especially like it when
they do it like you fancy feels
especially be franchise and stuff I want
to see more stuff like this and lower
the Rings and sometimes they did but the
Senate ography and this even though it
looks wonderful it's not trying to show
off it's trying to make you feel like
you're really there but still make you
feel the side but not in the JJ okay now
not in the Peter like I'm just going to
I'm just gonna say it
I don't think this was as good of a
story in some senses as force awakens
was but I run a characters uh yeah you
know the two main leaves like I think
Daisy Ridley and what's the things were
we're more interesting characters but I
think this is a way better crafted movie
than force awakens
like way better crafted I think the
cinematography and the you know I don't
handle it depends on what you're saying
if talking about characters I'd be like
oh no its force awakens but if you're
talking about I like and I'm talking
about the way it's visually represented
the crap that went into this to make you
feel like you're really in the world and
the so many of the action scenes in the
Abrams whom I thought it had that
handheld quality but you couldn't quite
make up what was going on I bet finale
the the x-wing finale and fourth gate
and I thought this one's a lot bearable
it is this one is like something out of
Return of the Jedi it's amazing and if
they do this like do we get oh no we
can't give it away but they want to uh
some of the things they do with the
space battle at the end are just
fantastic and hilarious and we were just
like we're laughing and the crowd was
cheering and it's epic and huge and it's
every essing thing I wanted and forth
awakens it they didn't give it to be
it's like here's a here's a few x-wing
saguni see and that way it blows up you
know like like with the prequels I know
it's like oh don't forget the prequels
but you know the C spells in that well
not bad we're not really good either and
I felt like this is probably the first
movie that took the faith valve at least
the kind of the next level of one wicked
consonant what you get with it these
space battles mukacheve originally you
have a sense of space and Weston space
literally yeah and what's going on and
my problem with the prequel battles and
it also transferred to force awakens
kind of is I never quite felt exactly
what the hell was going on it was too
jumbled and this one is it's like the
battles in the Empire Jedi or New Hope
you can see everything that's going on
and it's really awesome to watch and
they do things where they attach
basically but I mean it's CGI but what
would be the camera to the back of the
x-wings they follow the x-wing doing all
these maneuvers and it really feels like
classic Star Wars space battles I've
been missing that for decades but like
it's not just the space valves they also
take it kind of next level with some of
the things they do like there's one
scene where uh was a star two stories
comes out of hyperspace and it's a man
it does it out of nowhere so it's just
something up here and all these ships
are going and some of the ships crash
into it
yeah yeah what happened but we have
never seen that there's a lot there's a
lot of like questions you would have
about how these things in space would
work over the years that you're right
you've never seen it like what are you
just hyperspace right in front of it
like what did you just grab that you
yeah man yeah they jaw and that's that's
great
um we should probably talk about some of
the CG people okay now this is where it
is not a better crafting honey no um
it's really terrible I don't want to say
pear I don't want to say okay here okay
here's here's the thing you remember
Tron the latest Tron movie where they
had young Jeff Bridges it's kind of like
that and in Peter Cushing's case if he
doesn't talk I actually kind of buy it
like I'm like yeah I can see that like
it looks like like Peter Cushing through
yeah like I'm going to open his mouth
I'm like no honey Nate yeah it's like
watching woody the cowboy talk if Evelyn
his mouth is moving it's just like ah
yeah and then they have one more at the
end I guess we can give it away
technically but they have one more at
the end and that was done very well if
you look closely it's kind of the same
mouth problem but it's done much much
better and all my shooting me I thought
that was a lady for the I thought that
was worse than Peter could really I
thought that maybe of the big tree maybe
I don't know but I thought that no I
that's just that creeped me out
you know reminds me you with these
remind me of this damn Robert Zemeckis
motion cat all the Polar Express and
Beowulf me out of it the Christmas Carol
that he's yeah yeah that's what I
reminds me of in that last one I thought
was the worst that just like kinda looks
like something out of windows Robert
Zemeckis pounds give me yes the only I
thought I remember looking for you the
only one I bought because it was so
quick as I'm pretty sure they
resurrected some of the pilots from a
new hope like I'm pretty sure gold
leader was the actual or was it red
leader red one of them was the older guy
who gets blown up in a new hope you know
Lou but set up for your attack remote
was where Horton Center was pork in that
market what yes yeah hey fella
consulting hey wisss yeah no problem
here yeah yeah for all the like
stereotyping done in the prequel like
the most
oh all the guys pork Oh
so the the space battles were amazing
and Darth Vader oh my god you will shit
okay well I fight this way there is more
than yeah either one out here it is
there's more at first set up oh really
this all we're not ready well he may
disappear in CA yeah there's these real
Joseph he lives his business in like
fucking more doors yeah I can't tell
that supposed to be most of our from
Revenge of the Sith or whatever but it
is he wins in Barrett or like it and he
just takes a permanent bath until people
show up um and its how like okay tells
me whatever but he he comes back would
he come back the same handsome pieces it
is like self awesome me it is like
something out of like aliens evil dead
it is a code those are Gators yeah it
goes like full-on horror film is like
I'm not making this up and like I really
just wanted to cut to like Bruce
Campbell cartoon screaming uh yeah yeah
oh my god it was legitimately kind of
scarier than that you want to apply
we're going as - yeah it's just holy
shit you know does this bill I probably
would have my favorite Vader moments out
cuz you know how pissed he is I think um
the whole feel of this film you know it
doesn't start with the Star Wars a
little scroll and stuff like that drinks
that day uh look at this guy should yeah
this is not numb am I the only one who
gives a fuck about me I totally disagree
because I think the whole feel of this
film is different I think it's supposed
to be more of like you know quite
frankly considering how kind of confused
we were in the first 20 minutes I could
have used the story crawl
no way you got it okay you figure that I
yeah you know what it whenever I played
the games back in the 90s they still
would have the story crawl and they
didn't have to market episode you just
knew it would know our words and it
would just give the title in the story
crawl and I like this is a spin-off
movie that's going to have a slightly
different tone it's not going to be as
much the fun te ha ha you know it is
gonna be location as are so ridiculous
when all the sort of cuts to the title
and then you get you know some sort of
fakie Star Wars saga
well why did I say what they had was
better oh I just think I'm like if
you're gonna wear that why not oh no no
story well I think you guys had a
stronger opening but I feel like is they
should have done that because it's not
part of this you know sort of new
trilogy that they're doing and I feel
like it's more like hey just you ever
wondered what you know happened here
well here's what has always not like one
of the huge movies one of the nightmares
v film no I'm very girl is that because
I feel like you can then just let that
on anything you know I guess why people
hate the prequels because it's like what
is it has to opening and the story crawl
and everything is just like damn it like
this is a Star Wars film and with this
one it's like it's a Star Wars story
like you know what sighs I fuckin hate
that um no no I guess okay we used to
play these games uh growing up here by
LucasArts and they were these Jedi
Knight games and I'll say about before
horses yeah yeah the second one had a
much different feel than any of the
other Star Wars movies and I was totally
okay with that because this one doesn't
have as much you know sort of the space
wizards and the boards and stuff like
that this is much more like the military
this is much more the underground and
trying to keep what weapons this was
Gogarty yes this really a war war movie
qumola movie list is not yes this does
not have that much fantasy in em so and
I really don't care about because that
makes the world feel more real it feels
like it has more dimension taste the
Battle of Hoth and mix it with the
Battle of Endor and remove the Ewoks
that's what this spells gonna cost mixed
with a black
oh yeah it is but I mean it's all those
war movie parts of Star Wars - most of
the things that make it cute this is not
a cute movie no I had a damn Ewok in
sight there's the droid is the cutest
thing and anything that's off Dredd he's
he's just snarky look you kind of a he's
kind of a d-bag yeah yeah we're a yeah
with this new character that's brought
up more you know the woman is just like
you know any chance you can die I'm okay
with you know he's yeah oh family okay
with it so there's no this is probably
the bleakest star war know any and I
feel that fire strike no and that's the
tone that's this world and I feel like
that not you assertive episode 2.5 or
whatever you know I feel like an empire
no but Empire still has these regional
r2d2 little you on one might like that I
want my position I thought this was
America I want my fucking cross um no I
actually really like that like them I
mean it was good later listen if that's
the biggest problem I have with this
like that yeah yeah but but it is
something that did with JIT AB Italy
bothering like I really want my fucking
crawl I felt like every other there are
rules here where the other films when
they've done Ryan everything are fun
this I feel is like badass it is cool
it's badass it's not fun SSSs but it's a
cool yeah but not not to be fun but
here's the thing they also didn't give
you a serious title anyway it was still
goofy so why not just do the crawl then
I say you could still done that opening
better but it why point freaking tie
fighter you're playing as the bad guys
and they still had the crawl of course
it did be Imperial March over there
I don't know I will like that but the
yeah the feel of this is definitely
tells like actually sounds like a James
Bond movie like The Killers a kind of
hot around like elimination oh yeah
there's no benefit today's the new ones
where they're hopping around to
different exotic locations and there's
spies and be able to getting shot and
left and right and yeah so it's a
it's a you know a good flick I mean I
say the big problems are you know jumps
around a bit too much the two main
characters are not very interesting but
they're not awful either you know they
don't drag it down force awakens I
thought was just good for the most part
the whole way through just like yeah
that's always a steady level of good
this one starts up kind of like and then
ends great yeah like it and like it
starts off and you're kind of thinking
like cause that's really going to be
that good and by about the halfway point
it picks up and then that pole climbing
all the way to the very end it's just
freaking of media it's really really
cool so I and I give it props with that
because I'm like I'd rather end on a
high note because I'm probably more
jazzed about it
I can't because because it ended so
awesome I'm guessing it's like the
reverse Suicide Squad when I had like a
good first 40 minutes and then the rest
is guy got less and less to sorter it
off less and I just got so freakin cool
with the last 40 minutes that's just
like okay I'm right um what's what's be
honest that's also what a new hope did
like whenever I watch a new hope but it
all starts off pretty strong
it starts off strong but the whole
middle part of that movie like idea
really is
I am always tempted sometimes to fast
forward but then you get to that for
when they get to Yavin 4 and from that
point on all the way to the end when
they blow up the Death Star that's some
of the best shit my question by the way
there's a cameo and I think it's okay if
we say it is the testicle mouth guy and
then the penis nose guys everything
sound like French to me um you are the
hot jokes
yeah they make an appearance on this
planet you know in this town users in
this village awesome okay you know so
that's the final te ha ha the village
gets destroyed so did they make it out
or what cuz he desperately created a
paradigm yeah well it was a spaceport I
just assumed they were heading towards
their shit I guess I don't know I guess
he is luggage in three systems or vats
and whatever was that was probably my
favorite cameo the you know
c-3po yeah I don't think it's a guy way
lasers are very logically in there
sar Wolowitz c-3po and r2d2 are there
for like five seconds and I might give
this shit you know and I guess maybe
that's what they want to do because
they're in every single one but I'm kind
of like you know what I don't if you're
not gonna have the opening scroll you
don't need to poem in this um so uh yeah
try to think not too much else I mean it
is a good moment you know go see it it
is a little different it is real it what
you moving it it starts up goodish and
gets really great but yeah um it's a if
you watch the trailer and you say yeah I
think that'd be fun that's okay it is a
cool little badass movie I've got some
badass pirates but some slow boring
parts too and it could have been better
yeah but what are some pretty awesome
scenes in there tailings that mostly at
the end of the greatest Vader moment
yeah and I did yeah the audience like
they were like applauding laughing
screaming anything nice I think there
are some kids that were like flipping
out like there were like little kids
it's this thing it's like what you're
not going to get it and it's it saved up
to I get I think this movie can don't
how to say that stuff because you don't
see as much of like the lightsabers and
the forest and stuff like that so what
do you do get to anything why and you
know it's even more interesting when you
feel like the blind guy when he uses the
force and the end faith and stuff like
that you know he's sort of the minority
in this like he's not surrounded by
people they're like yeah a lot of us can
use the Force or whatever so it seems
like all the more precious when you know
that stuff is being done um so yeah
actually generally honestly generally
when they're blowing shit up that's
wouldn't yeah that is everyone is the
funny because I thought that was such
the opposite of the prequels I thought
some of the action scenes are so
overdone but this is the opposite I'm
like man when they won't shit up this
movies on yeah and I mean to be fair
there's tons of scenes where they're
doing that yeah but I'm not blowing shit
up it's just an okay movie yeah but
yeah it's pretty awesome so um go see
them blow shit up and what you see you
next me the force be bring back the
scroll okay